what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video on weights and biases i'm a
little late to the party on weights and
biases because the name
juan db i don't know to me i see that
name and it just makes me think of like
i don't know like these like pop-up you
know cheap electronics brands companies
or something on amazon i don't know it's
just my spam filter filtered out 1db
so anyway um i have had since had the
time to play with this i've been using
this now for
probably like a couple months
and uh i am a huge fan of this product
so uh first of all it is completely free
to use for personal projects and uh if
you want to use it commercially then
there is like some licensing involved
and uh you can also run it locally as
well there are some arbitrary limits
still to run it locally so even if it's
your personal project and you want to
run it locally there's still some sort
of limit i want to say it's like 100
gigabytes or something so it's pretty
it's pretty hard to hit that limit
unless you're trying to log lots of
videos and imagery or something like
essentially frames um then you might hit
that limit but otherwise i think it
would be pretty challenging
anyway um yeah so it's free to use for
your personal project so if you're
someone who like uses tensorboard but
you often find yourself um you know kind
of moving your tensorboard log doors
around to like show it all on one page
or even more so
making really long log directory names
to contain things like your hyper
parameters and all that
chances are this might be for you also
if you forget like what were the
settings that i used to create that log
because a lot of times you'll use the
same script you'll edit things you'll
run it again then you'll edit again run
it again and so some things might just
be like lost
if any of that resonates with you
chances are you will love weights and
biases
so uh let's check it out let's see a
really basic example it's really quick
and easy to actually just like get
started here um to begin go to
wandb.ai you create an account and then
if you just go to 1db.ai
settings you can come down here and
there's an api key if you just scroll
down i'm just not going to show it
my other only other complaint with like
besides like local storage is what you
see right here
weights and biases if anyone from waste
and biases is watching when i hit and
maybe it's because of my browser maybe
because i'm using brave it just doesn't
actually save it to a cookie or
something i don't know
but
they will hound the heck out of you so
uh if anybody from waste biases is
watching at least either that thing is
not working or like let me choose it as
a setting maybe in my profile but also
stop emailing me all that
like it's okay to ask for feedback but
they email so much uh you gotta stop but
the product is so good that uh if you
wanna keep reaching out and asking me if
i'm enjoying weights and biases um i'll
still continue using your product so
anyways uh continuing on uh so once you
have your api key you'll come over to a
terminal and it is a pip 3 install 1db i
already have it so i'm not going to run
it and then once you have weights and
biases it's just 1db
uh login not ogen
login and then when you go to login you
will paste that api key
so that's the initial setup and
from there what we're going to do is i'm
going to
uh this script so this is a really basic
tensorflow
um example script now this will you
there you can tie in weights and biases
to
not just tensorflow and keras but also
pi torch but even more so than that you
can tie it into
let me see if i have it up
right so even more than that you have
all these other integrations so there's
all of these versions of tensorflow for
example hugging face spacey fast ai
scikit learn
there's even other integrations uh maybe
here i'll see yeah i've been using it
with stable bass lines three for example
so there are tons of ways that you can
very easily integrate this and even if
it's not here well everything at the end
of the day is using tensorflow or
pytorch so you can still integrate it so
it's just whether or not it's just gonna
be like super quick and easy or you're
gonna have to dig into source code so um
anyway uh coming back to our simple
example from you know just a tensorflow
example uh to to begin using it there's
essentially like three things that you
need to do so the first thing is we're
going to import 1db so import weights
and biases and then it is from
wandyb dot uh and in this case is it
keras callbacks
it's a 1db dot
keras import
1db call
back okay
so we definitely need to make those
imports next we need to initialize so
1db dot init and you can pass quite a
few things into init but for now we're
just going to pass the project name
which in our case we will just call it
1db tutorial
once you've initialized the last thing
that we need to do is i'm going to copy
that callback and down in model.fit this
is where you would pass your callback so
if you were using tensorboard you would
also pass your tensorboard here but for
now callbacks will just equal a list
where it is quite literally just the
weights and biases callback
and that is it that's all you have to do
so i'll save that come over here we will
uh python
python3 1db video.pi
we'll run that and we can immediately
see okay we're logging in and hopefully
here in a second we'll start to see the
actual thing is training and things are
being saved so coming now over to
weights and biases i'll go to projects
and we should see a new project here in
a second now
there it is so i can click on that and
actually we can see here this is the new
project we can see it's running because
of this little green dot interestingly
enough we can actually click here and
stop the runs um
and also now it's actually already done
so i'm not going to going to stop it but
in theory you could and you might think
oh that's kind of silly but actually i
found that to be very useful because you
can usually you can put more models on a
gpu
than is like the most efficient to run
any single model so maybe you're running
five models on that gpu and like five
models fits
but
you know if you were running three
models those models would at least step
faster so there's been plenty of times
where i'm not near a computer i don't
have shell access maybe via my phone or
whatever and i'm actually just tracking
things and waits in pisces and on my
phone i'll just be like okay that
model's not working and i'll just kill
it on my phone
and now my other models can at least
step faster also sometimes i just get
curious when i check it on my phone i
i don't think i've ever hosted my own
tensor tensorboard sessions you you can
you could publicly host uh your
tensorboard that's just a simple web
server i don't even know if that's like
a secure i don't know if it's actually a
smart idea to do so
but you could um so anyways so here's
our run we have some of the more basic
things that you might want to track here
um
we also have so you've got accuracy the
epoch that we're on and loss uh and then
we also just have like these system
metrics and stuff that are tracked but
we can track a whole lot more
than just what we're doing here so this
was just a really quick example of like
how quickly can we get up and running so
from here the next thing that i think is
really useful to have is just the fact
that it can track your hyper parameters
to the point where
you're not having these really long
in the past i would call them really
long log names um whereas now you can
keep using these random names or you can
set the name but you don't pass all your
hyper parameters in the name so
coming back to our code what i'm going
to do i think i'm this is all from a
text-based write-up so if you want to
copy and paste or want to follow along
just go to the text-based version
because i'm not going to be writing out
obviously all of this and then what i'm
going to show you now is just a quick
example so i'm just going to copy and
paste it from the tutorial
so in this case i'll also set this to
1 so i'm not on the recording gpu
anymore
and this was copied from the tutorial
thank you
so so let's say these are your like
hyper parameters now in this case these
are some really basic hyper parameters
these are just from the uh the
benchmarking that i've been doing on
weights and biases
um but you you there will be times where
obviously you're going to have way more
hyper parameters than even just these
few like these few could fit in just
like a name
but we don't need it
and then once you have your hyper
parameters you make this config dict and
in this case we're just going to track
okay what was the gpu the machine name
how many gpus and whether or not we're
envy linked again this is just just to
have an example of some either hyper
parameters or just other information
that you want to track you can put
anything in there that you wanted and
then let me just copy and paste the new
init method so no time is wasted here
and here we can see okay we've got that
um i don't think i capitalized the b let
me check this yeah okay so
let me fix that before we end up
creating a new project
an entity is just what user made it the
config is this config dict here and
again you can pass whatever the heck you
wanted um
the sync tensorboard in this case we're
not i'm not going to type out
tensorboard but i'll show you an example
of when you can sync tensorboard and
then finally um if you want to assign a
name to the run you can and this is just
me doing it
and again we have so few configurations
in this case that it's not as important
and not as useful but i will i'll show
you in a moment that
i have some with like 20 plus parameters
and it's extremely useful so uh so with
these changes i'll go ahead and just
save that and come back over here we
will run it and possibly if i can be
quick quick enough uh as soon as i see
it going i'll uh come on well i'll just
move it over here and what i'll do is
i'll come back to
come back to here
and hopefully if i just oh it's our
actually already there
um so for example we actually can from
the web we can just stop this and
obviously it doesn't have to happen on
the same local computer and it just
sends the kill signal and as as you can
see we actually did get the keyboard
interrupt um i think that's really cool
and like such a simple little feature uh
that i you would think is like oh that's
kind of silly um i actually really like
it
so anyway
so cool
okay so that's like a really quick you
know here are some quick things that you
can do and then now let me just kind of
show you um at least some of the things
that i've used weights and biases for so
coming over to basically the okay we'll
show the benchmarker first so this is me
comparing different gpus so one it's
just obviously it's really quick for me
to compare various gpus and various
settings that i've run um this
benchmarking script on but also like for
example i don't there might be a way to
i'm sure there's a way in tensorboard to
do like bar charts and very custom line
charts and line graphs
but to my knowledge like this graph here
this graph would be impossible on
a tensorboard because if you add a
custom chart
you can only the thing that you would
track would be the one gpu temperature
whereas so like if i go
um
like two gpus like yeah so here we're
running with two gpus but we're tracking
the temperature
of
both gpus on that same chart whereas in
tensorboard one of the things that's
annoying is if you do want to track
custom stuff each single custom thing
that you want to track has to be its own
new chart um just one example of one
annoying pain point and maybe feel free
to comment below if i'm incorrect here
maybe there is a way to do it but i
haven't figured it out and here i didn't
even have to think about it like the
charts are just automatic and whether or
not something's a bar chart or a line
chart
at least pretty well wandy b kind of
guesses which one you would want and
makes it that chart but you can always
go in here and you can edit each of the
panels
and change basically everything about
that chart right um and then also you
can always add a new panel and make it a
line chart bar chart scatter plot all of
these things
so
um there's just so much customization
that you can do here plus you know like
let's say with gpu temperature for
example if you come here you could go to
legend and we can edit like let's say
this is our baseline or something we can
make that like a thicker line and all
this stuff and again maybe this is all
possible in tensorboard um
but i do find that beyond very basic
things you just can't do it in
tensorboard so again so for for
comparing things even in this case we're
actually comparing gpus we're not even
trying to compare just models
um i find this to be extremely useful
then obviously when we're comparing gpus
things like gpu
memory allocated and and all this kind
of stuff it's just very useful to have
but even if you're just training models
again it's very useful to know like the
bigger model does it take longer to
train how does it compare against maybe
smaller models and our resource
allocation and all that especially if
you're trying to test models that you
might be running live um
all that so yeah tons of information
here and then the next thing i want to
show
i'll use the biddle rl7 this is me doing
uh reinforcement learning with stable
bass lines three again uh to incorporate
that it was just like i wanted there's a
specific callback so it's just a
different callback and that's basically
it
and again in this case
so for example i'm actually these are
two of the exact same chart and again
this is something i couldn't
i don't think it's possible to do in
tensorboard so it's actually the same
the same data
so the data is the reward so obviously a
lot of times you're going to be tracking
maybe
um
loss or accuracy but in terms of
reinforcement learning i'm very
interested in okay well what's the
average reward that's what we care about
so in this case i actually want to see
the average reward
both in terms
of um
well relative time can be useful but in
this case i kind of like i like the
actual like wall time just purely
because
um
over time i'm making edits so for
example like this this this run was a a
reloaded so basically like the training
i loaded that model back in and
continued training well if we only
looked at that in terms of step for
example it's like restarting now with
stability size three you can modify that
so that like wouldn't happen but anyways
i want to see both i want to see the
step comparison and then i also want to
see
over time because again some models will
actually step faster so it's not just a
question of
what did the model learn in 10 000 steps
it's what sometimes we also care well
what are the how long did it take that
model to do that so these two charts i
like to see but in tensorboard you can
only have all your charts indexed by um
you know wall time or relative time or
step
uh whereas here you you can have
whatever you want with whatever charts
it doesn't even have to be these two
charts right so um anyway i i really
like that um
the system stuff i wouldn't track so
much here and also these charts are
gonna be just like crazy amounts of
information because i have so many runs
that we're like looking at um
but one of the other cool things for
example is if we can get away from our
laggy charts we can come over to this
table
and this table again is is really cool
um
this this is we're tracking this we have
basically all of our hyper parameters
but then also just other information so
again we get some
initial observation our last observation
information we get um how far are we
into the training how long has this
model been running blah blah blah i mean
there's everything is here you can i
think you can see yeah this is like
scroll bar there's so much information
here um and you could you can remove
columns from the table add them
all that also like in my case since
everything is discrete delta
and this by this time i think everything
actually probably has the same discrete
delta um
numbers but but
initially that wasn't the case and they
were actually different
um different little bins and again all
these things like i don't even know how
would you encode that into like just a
log files save name you'd have to have
like some sort of notes text file that
kind of helped you to cross reference
all this stuff whereas
here it's just all it just helps so much
with the with the organization
um and then finally to when you get to
the point same thing with like hertz
that was another thing that was changing
between a lot of models now it's not
but these are all like frame stack hertz
uh discrete delta these are all things
that i've added like these are
configuration things that i just wanted
to make sure was saved into the training
but of course i didn't add that to the
name because again if i put everything
in the name it would be like you know
600 characters so i can click on like
one of the runs like let's say i really
like this run here um and i want to play
that locally so
i the log files in my case the way i
saved them was just like the time stamp
of when the model started training so
but i don't know that timestamp i don't
remember so i click on that model and
then once that model actually loads
basically what we're seeing is just all
the like the charts but just for like
the one model again this is all
customizable i could make this however i
wanted uh but very rarely am i looking
at just one model here but then i can go
to the overview again just for this one
specific model
and i know it was it's like something
name or something like that so if i just
type in name model save name boom i've
got the timestamp again it's like
everything is just really quickly and
easily accessible tracked all that stuff
like i it's just i i don't know how i
would do this again without like some
sort of sloppy file or something
um and then also another cool thing that
you like i just would never
give this to myself but it's nice to
have
is uh the logs so we can pull up the
logs and these are quite literally your
console logs like as this thing has run
it just saves all of the logs and if
you're ever hitting errors or there's so
many times where you're going to want to
have b
you'd like to be able to go back and
read the logs but you can't because who
saves their logs right i don't anyways
but they're here and they're saved
the other cool thing let's say um like
for example tensorboard so if you did
also if you were also running
tensorboard you had the actual
tensorboard saved uh we can click on
this this will probably also take a
moment so yeah take it up to 30 seconds
um so once that's done i'll show you the
tensorboard all right and here we have
the
basic tensor board that is given to us
from um this is just the stable
baselines three baseline tensorboard and
as you can see there's way less
information here we have no way of if we
wanted more charts
we would have to go in there and
customize the code and add those charts
and that would just be a nightmare i
just i would not do it so
so anyway
but if you needed tensorboard for some
reason or you're using a project that
does have a really cool tensorboard
chart that uh you don't have or you're
you can't figure out with weights and
biases for example you could still load
up tensorboard this way as well
so
um overall i mean we're already i'm just
longer than i wanted to make this video
anyways but overall there's just so much
here so much to use it's free
uh
i would definitely recommend using it
so the last thing i'll just mention is
sweeps i haven't personally used much of
sweeps but uh if you're looking for
something kind of like the keras tuner
or something like that you can check out
sweeps they also have some documentation
here
and essentially you can kind of like
copy one of their projects and stuff but
they also will like it's super simple as
long as it makes sense to be using
sweeps in my case
uh i could only like run so many of
these simulations at a time that it
makes i just would rather manually go
through it
but for many projects many models it
would make a lot of sense to just like
quickly run through just as many as as
you can at a time and quickly like
search for like the best parameters so
anyways there's also that there you can
copy one of their projects and just kind
of get an idea for like how that's
working but it's just automated hyper
parameter tuning so anyways i think
that's everything i really want to show
about weights and biases at least for
now if you think i forgot something or
you want to you want to highlight one of
the features of weights and biases if
you've been using it that you like
let me know below
otherwise i'll leave it here
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
i will see you all in another video
you